hey guys welcome to nerding out this is
a show where we get GameSpot's nerds
together to talk about shows that we
like and today we're talking about
Westworld Season one Episode five
contrapasso let's jump into theories
I've got buddy Austin and gage here and
I'm chastity
so welcome let's talk about theories
guys timelines Lincoln fever sketch I
don't know what's happening so I feel
like they're trying to throw us off
because we see Lawrence twice and did he
have enough time to reset because I'm
not sure if he did because we see him in
my base timeline and we see him Logan
and William meet him I mean some of that
I think they intentionally intentionally
put it in such a way where were led to
like believe could it be could it not be
like last week I was convinced a time on
theory was just out the window and now
this week I'm convinced if or right back
into play well yeah when he likes life
Lawrence's throat spoilers when he did
that he made a point to say oh they'll
be back a little bit to clean him up
and then almost immediately we now see
like William loading them all going in
there and encountering him right there
and part of me think like this is not
the same timeline like I think they're
in very different times but they're
trying to frame it in such a way where
you're just led to keep second-guessing
so they're throwing us off because Logan
mensches mentions Arnold's death but he
doesn't say how many years have passed
so it could still be two different
timelines I think that's them going oh
no they're all in the same timeline but
are they don't know I'm still a question
right I mean I think the whole like when
they were just going there Dolores just
kept zoning out it seemed and looked
like she was alone I think that was an
intentional way where you're like issue
zoning out or is she actually retracing
her steps as she went on this 20 years
ago with William and Logan and is she
just going through to try to refigure
out what is this maze about as she's
trying to find Arnold or find whoever it
is she's talking to in her head she
is that a couple of times as well like
the whole like feeling like she's been
there before or I can't remember the
exact line but that's that's great
that's a great man yeah that's a great
theory yeah that's awesome so speaking
about Arnold let's talk about Austin yes
so there is an aural this time so Loras
is working with him yeah I feel like
they laid a lot out on Arnold
in this episode that I felt like oh I
know more about him but now I know less
about because we know he's alive in some
form or fashion whether that's just some
consciousness of him that he's implanted
into the hosts but you know it's
interesting to me because we talked last
week about how we have Ford who's now
like oh my god and I feel like Arnold is
constantly a step ahead of him in this
game and of course we now know that
divorce is talking to Arnold is hearing
his voice hearing his voice which also
kind of touches back on last week is the
dissonance theory of saying you know are
they are they thinking are the hosts
thinking they're hearing God's voice or
do they know it's Arnold or you know how
are they processing that and another
point that I thought is cool to make
that if you go to the west-world website
they have a chat bot on there that you
can talk to and I was asking it who is
Arnold and it starts kind of you know
jabbering on and then it gets cut off
and has an ear and error come up and
within the error it says hell is empty
it gives me butterflies you know slowly
but surely revealing himself all the
Devils are here yes so the man in black
starts talking about aural and he kind
of has him in more regard when he's
talking to Ford he's just like Arnold is
the real creator of this park and like
this part almost failed so what are we
thinking what did you get out of that
conversation between Ford and the man in
black so I've been watching rewatching
episodes
number one this is very strange but I
think the in that conversation what I
got out of it is forward is definitely
Arnold's creation the man in black the
man in black was like dude
Arnold created this world and then you
know killed himself killed himself
killed himself or did you kill him the
reason why I think that Arnold is is the
like the creator of Ford of everything
he's because of the way that the man in
black didn't hold him in deference you
know Arnold and deference it was kind of
annoyed by him mm-hmm
not maybe not annoyed but just treated
him just like everybody else everybody
else he noticed he threatened him and
Teddy went into this crazy like Teddy is
dead Teddy's full of full of
what's-his-name
he's got gallons of L as it was and all
of a sudden just goes and gets all crazy
with the night yeah I mean that that was
automatic like I said it before I think
Ford's tapping the matrix because he's
because he's a host
he's a host he hangs out with other
hosts he he's he's got no compassion for
other hosts right and I don't know it
doesn't I mean it doesn't add up
I think though I agree I'm not a hundred
percent soul that he's a host but I
really like the theory that he is yeah I
mean mean yeah but I mean I think I
think the theory is cool I also think
from episode 2 the storyline of Wyatt
sub 1 episode 2 episode 2 I think that
that is the story of Arnold and Ford I
think that Arnold is Wyatt and he's like
a big evil to Ford so better there was
yeah
and I might be going completely crazy
but it was like it's so weird how Arnold
has I mean Ford has a lot of these like
reverence moments reverie moments yeah
that are like you know and it's so much
like one of the the scripted things that
the hosts are saying even though he's
obviously not scripted and completely
you know just making things up analysis
it's like now you don't know who to root
for and like are they both fill-ins is
one more so than the other and then the
whole idea that maybe Ford's Soho's yeah
I'll say when I ain't that in Hopkins
and Ed Harris set down across the table
I was like now this is whatever he is
this is amazing at it I agree okay so we
cannot ignore that Elsie found a device
inside that hosts arm yeah and what was
that what does it mean you have an idea
so I'm convinced that they were giving
hints towards in this episode towards
what it is and I think when Logan made a
point to tell William about how his
company knows about the hemorrhaging
money West world has and like yeah and
how they want to buy it and like how do
they know all this and I think that they
have that insider like who's working
with them I don't know but someone
planted that device inside his arm
someone remotely controlling the hosts
outside of the park remotely controlling
and gathering that data and I think when
L see and I think his name was Stubbs
like came across that host who was going
up there I think he intentionally
destroyed his mind to try to like almost
like a self-destruct protocol to get rid
of whatever information he could I think
that way the they can't even find
whatever is going on there and her
discovering that with only because she
had that insider info on neck Roper very
interesting yeah we we got to see a lot
of these people that were behind the
scenes that we hadn't seen before and
they're developing their storylines and
they're very interesting so now we have
Maeve though I feel like was awake the
entire episode it does
gathering that information for blackmail
and now she's gonna use Felix and yeah
she's you see in like the preview for
next week that she's gonna use him
probably to like programs or coding all
right it's like don't mess with my head
I want him to keep everything definitely
waited till he learned how to code that
bird like she was waiting and biding her
time told the bird she like it's time
it's time he's ready he's ready oh I
love it the girl power at the end of
this oh yeah see what Dolores and the
gun I'm not a damsel anymore the story
in which I'm not a damsel leave yeah man
yeah it's pretty awful horas and may
have taken control mm-hmm the real
heroes are what's right why am i rooting
for robots I don't know but they're
great they're great that's what can I
say yeah so what about that preview of
things to come
I mean I don't know what the timeline is
but there is a lot of naked maven it
yeah I think there's just gonna be a lot
my prediction tons more naked Maeve in
the series yeah yes so we're gonna see
there's a lot more of explosion
explosion I saw those so yeah yeah we
fit a relationship brimming between
Dolores and Williams what is that it's
true they're gonna be the Romeo and
Juliet of this series and if William and
I start turning black hat maybe like he
said I'm not pretending anymore right
yeah but he was proud of me like he's
doing it so next week is called the
adversaries of join us for talk about
Westworld next week and I atrocity with
buddy Austin and catch thanks for
joining us
this was turning out see you next week
nerds oh yeah